welcome back to new rockstars i'm
whitney van laningham and get your
interdimensional cable remotes ready
because rick and morty is coming back
for season six on sunday september 4th
at 11 p.m on adult swim i'm super
excited to tell y'all that i'll be
covering breakdowns and theory videos
for rick and morty this season and i'm
fully prepared to squanch ass and take
names today i'm going to break down the
official trailer speculate on what the
hell wermageddon is and tell you
everything we can expect to see in rick
and morty season 6. the trailer opens up
with rick and jerry crouching outside of
a busted up panda express let's take a
brief moment of silence for the fast
food employees that are gonna have to
deal with rick and morty fans for the
next two months okay rick is holding
what i'm gonna call boombox blasters
that seem to be more fashionable than
functional two seconds later rick asks
his ship to play track 1 on his
favorites playlist aka the song paranoid
by black sabbath this episode is
probably another classic rick and jerry
adventure but this time jerry is dressed
like a morty in a clip towards the end
of the trailer we see rick scan morty
jerry who's holding a small slip of
paper rick seems surprised by the result
of the scan and i have a theory about
why you know how ricks use mortys to
hide themselves from their enemies
because the morty waves cancel out their
genius waves what if morty can't go on
this adventure so rick dressed up jerry
as his grandson had him read lines in
character and scanned him to see if he
could pass as a morty rick exclaiming oh
after scanning jerry shows that this
faux morty is providing surprising
results but not perfect this shootout
shows that jerry ultimately isn't morty
enough and danger will eventually find
rick next we see sentient and heavily
armed household appliances destroy the
smith sanchez home in the center of the
living room a garbage bag filled with
potatoes a carton of eggs an energy
drink can a bowling ball and sausage
links make up what looks to be a
low-tech bomb or device could we be
seeing the uprise of the butter bot in
his ilk
oh my god when we see the bots later in
the trailer the house is under the same
lockdown defense protocol we saw in
season five's multiplicity to me this
suggests that the robot revolt is coming
from inside the house in the garage rick
fiddles with some sort of new hologram
casting device as he loads a blue
triangular bulb into a half dome with
three holes he clarifies to morty that
they're not gonna die they're just gonna
vanish from this reality which is
totally different space beth is standing
with the rest of the family so it's safe
to assume that this scene takes place in
the first episode of the season bethic
twinstink also in this shot the oral gun
charging station on the garage wall
still looks to have some leftover portal
fluid inside in the season 5 finale we
learned that evil morty poisoned the
citadel's regulated supply of fluid so
this might be the last of their precious
reserve over at the coolest goddamn
arcade in the galaxy blips and shits
rick and morty are fully plugged into
the roy matrix the vr life simulator roy
a life well lived first appeared back in
season two's morty night run but this
season the game gets its own full
episode episode six mort a life well
wrecked notice that both rick and
morty's eyes are fully whited out
something that also happens when they
plug into morty's mind blowers on the
game's screen roy appears to be giving a
speech on the steps of the stadium but
watch closely when summer shakes grandpa
rick awake roy glitches and slumps over
as soon as he opens his eyes rick tells
summer that a small group of alien
terrorists are taking over blips and
shits and it's up to her to pull a die
hard while he and morty finish up their
business with roy as summer replies that
she hasn't seen die hard two alien
terrorists escort their captives out of
the game room is it just me or do these
guys kind of remind you of jar jar then
we see a fleet of robot alien ships
firing lasers at rick and morty rick
activates a blast shield around the ship
and after the lasers slice through it we
see rick's brand new souped up ship for
the first time you'll notice that the
contraption that rick was building back
in the garage is plugged into the
dashboard of the ship and the items
powering it are a brown and yellow
rectangular bar that blue pyramid bulb
and a green cylinder with discs around
its tip fun detail when the ship is
powered off here the pyramid is blue
like it was in rick's garage but when we
see this device powered on later in the
trailer the pyramid blows pink it
projects a hologram with several planets
that rick flips through as they travel a
space bath rick takes out the bots by
firing blasts from cybernetic
modifications in his palms which we get
a close-up look at in another scene he
can also now detach his arms and
instantly regenerate a set of robot arms
to replace them as well as conjure a set
of laser whips rick's got several other
upgrades this season too he's got what
looks like iron spider armor that pops
out from underneath his suit jacket each
arm wielding a different weapon he's got
glowing nunchucks a power drill a broken
glass bottle an electrified tuning fork
a voodoo doll a flame blade and a
blaster honestly jerry my jaw would be
on the floor too but rick isn't the only
member of the family with super parts
summer finds a vending machine full of
various superhero weaponry like thor's
hammer cyclops's cool guest shades a
green magneto helmet and a single
glowing purple dice and a canister my
rogue theory is that it's the power
stone in cube form so that they don't
get sued by thanos for copyright
infringement screw that right yeah we're
not [ __ ] but realistically it's more
likely a gambit parody summer chooses
x-23's claws her arms morph and she
sprouts adamantium from between her
knuckles back at the home appliance
robot fight what looks like an angry
refrigerator leaps on the roof of the
smith's car while rick barefooted in
pajamas stands on the hood of a police
vehicle driven by summer the car's
bumper is riddled with bullet holes so
this part of the chase must take place
further along in the episode at blips
and shits summer evades two of the alien
terrorists with their own yipikaya
[ __ ] maneuvers she and both
aliens are in possession of small purple
aliens and glowing purple blasters
whatever those little guys are they're
holding on for dear life when she
tackles a terrorist across the lanes of
a skee-balls machine they both go
careening off the balconies somewhat
mirroring hans gruber's diehard death
next rick uses jerry as a human shield
as the two of them escape what appears
to be two secret service agents by
pulling their own john mcclane into a
vent see those earpieces the president's
back this season you lying dicks i see
your asses playing minecraft i got you
on satellite but either these agents
have stormtrooper aim or jerry somehow
repels bullets and rick is treating him
like captain america's vibranium shield
because he can't die hard soft or
otherwise the new ship sails through a
multicolored tunnel i'm honestly not
sure if this takes place inside the hole
that evil morty blew in the central
finite curve or if we have another
anatomy park situation on our hands if
it's the cfc those oblong rings could be
wonky-shaped portals to other
psychedelic universes but if it's the
inside of an organism those could also
be mitochondrial cells wherever they're
going in that fancy new ship rick is
tripping balls as beth rips out of the
driveway in the family car instructing
her loved ones to hold on to their dicks
the robot appliances are shooting loaded
syringe darts at the smith sanchez crew
we later see summer bail out of the cop
car just before it veers off the highway
and into a gasoline factory
interestingly this next shot takes place
in rick's intact original c-137 home at
the address 6910
69. this is the home where he lived with
diane and baby beth before they were
bombed by that other jackhole rick a
deflated arm at the bottom left of the
screen drops a letter which floats away
as the family pulls out of the garage
and rick's new ship i'm left wondering
does this scene take place in rick's
memory could that be where that groovy
portal led to finally we see why rick
had to upgrade his ship with their home
battened down with armor and armed with
alarms morty trips a laser that triggers
an explosion in the ship blasting it to
pieces nosey neighbor jean played by tom
kenney is back to inquire about his car
trouble i'm also curious about which
multiverse this comet lands in a morty
stands in the forest gazing in a
neighborhood covered in an overgrowth of
foliage this leads me to believe that
we're returning to the long abandoned
cronenberg universe which also became
overgrown the last time we saw it in the
rickshank redemption the end card poster
for season six is interesting too jerry
and summer's eyes are whited out as if
they're inside vr or a mind blower and
beth summer and jerry all have electric
green veins showing through their skin
beth's stomach is sliced open by a
portal of light and there's what i can
only describe as a butt-shaped golden
snitch flying after the family while
we're breaking down season six info a
few days ago adult swim posted a teaser
video called a citadel secret rick and
morty wermageddon evil morty's theme aka
for the damage coda by blonde redhead
begins to play and the 15 second clip
shows an unoccupied chamber of the
citadel in the moments right before and
during the collapse inside there's an
egg in a cylindrical incubator floating
in glowing green portal fluid the room
devolves into chaos red lights flashing
alarms blaring electrical explosions and
even a little red skull symbol on one of
the machines moments before the video
ends the cylinder protecting the egg
cracks oozing green portal fluid my
guess is that it won't be long before
the egg itself cracks too at the end of
the video a link to rick and morty.com
was made available if you click it
you're taken to the website where you'll
find a countdown clock to something
called wermageddon which will happen at
7pm pst 10 pm est on august 18th now
let's be real armageddon really could be
anything it could be a parody of
armageddon where worm bruce willis and
warren billy bob thornton have to drill
a hole in an asteroid about to destroy
earth it could be a recreation of the
1999 video game warm armageddon it could
be evil morty's final plan to rid the
multiverse of sanchez's and smith's for
good or it could even be a top secret
project by the council of ricks that's
about to be unleashed and unattended now
that the citadel is ash if this truly is
a secret weapon of the smartest men in
the multiverse one can only dread the
squiggly apocalypse that's about to
start unfolding two weeks before the
show returns follow me on instagram and
twitter whitneypuppy follow new
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you